hello YouTube chairs lovers and my
friends this is Gungan here welcome to
the 23rd episode of dirty chess tricks
in this episode I'm going to show you a
surprising trick and a shock weapon
against Sicilian tamaño or the pulse and
munition now the Sicilian time on a
variation arises after the water
efore c5 Knight to f3 now here there are
two ways black and reply black can play
Knight to c6 followed by the e6 but the
proper time on water is e 6 after d4 see
kept his d4 and Knight captures d4 now
black plays Knight to c6 so in other
words it is avoiding some bishop to be
fine lines here I'm proposing that I
should continue with the Moon Knight to
c3 and as I have alerted over here black
has few choices amongst them Queen to c7
is absolutely mainline but we should see
what's wrong with other moves
so the first move I want to consider is
a 6 which is surprisingly enough played
more often but I think the simplest
repetition is you can take this night
and now however black recapture he get a
bad position so for example if B capture
c6 then the simplest is you play e5 and
now somewhere down the line
black will have some isolated pawn on
the Queen side which of course gives
white a clear-cut targets now instead of
B capture c6 a black captures other way
then the problem can get even worse
because after Queen exchange generally
this black King in such a structures can
sit nicely on c7 but here it is white to
move and after the move Bishop to air
for not only that King cannot go to the
c7 but in the next move White is going
to castle on the Queen side and create
more problems to the black king
so this is a very wonderful position for
the white the second move Knight to f6
have some problems because here by force
white can transpose line into the
specialty covariation yes absolutely
right so here I will continue with the
move Knight to B Phi so idea is to play
Knight to d6 so black has to stop it
after that white will continue with the
move Bishop to error for attacking three
times on the d6 square so black has to
stop it one more time with the movie Phi
and after the move Bishop to g5 we
directly transpose into the swash Nico
variation after the move a six so as a
why definitely you are very much prepare
against faz Nico but as a black if you
are a time on or the pulsing player you
certainly not going to like this
structure the simple reason is tamaño is
more positional opening where this
opening is quite tactical so to cut the
long story short the main line continued
here with the move Queen to c7 and
exactly here our tricks start rolling so
the first move we are going to play is
Knight to be Phi attacking the Queen so
the Queen has to safeguard the d6 square
so he has to play Queen to b8 afterwards
we are going to continue with the move
Bishop to e3 now here it is very obvious
that black has to kick that night as
soon as possible so the a6 move looks
very natural but that is exactly white
once instead of a6 black can play or the
move such as Knight to f6 which is the
only other good reply but against this
we can continue here with the move f4 so
threatening the movie Phi now here a6
leads to the very bad position for black
and I have included a model game in the
PGN which is available in the
description so kindly go through it so
the main mu is d6 to stop the move e5
well afterwards white will continue with
the move Bishop to e2 a six-night to d4
Bishop to e7 castle on the kick side and
castle on the King side
we reach to the classical variation of
the Sicilian where white is a clear
tempo up as this Queen is clearly
misplaced and black has to waste one
more time PO to put back on the c7 so
this is again a great advantage to the
white okay so let's see what's wrong
with the MU a six after all its initial
move it's kicking deny it and what can
be the bed well here comes our shock
weapon with the MU the chef to be six
pair so we are sacrificing the whole
night and after pawn captures and Knight
captures white is indeed threatening
either Knight to c7 or Bishop to c7
Carly note black cannot play a casual
move for example let's say black
continued here with the move Knight to
f6 then after Bishop to c7 black queen
is a goner
haha so accordingly black has only three
moves in the picture
amongst them Bishop to b4 is the main
line but before that we have to see what
happens a black place at the most
so the first more I want to consider
this rook to e4 which has the idea of
attacking the e4 and giving space to the
Queen well against this I'm recommending
that Y should continue with the move
Knight to c7 check and after King to e7
you should continue with the move c4
so not only blocking the file but also
attacking the rook one of my game
continued here with the move rook to p4
attacking the bishop but then I continue
with the move Bishop to c5 and after
came to d8 I simply grabbed the bishop
in the corner so still white is
attacking the rook and the g7 pawn my
opponent continued here with the move
Knight to e7 I continue with the move
Bishop captures g7 and after the move
rook to g8 I simply attack black rook
with the move a3
my opponent plays rook to b6 the only
move to save his rook and now comes the
star mu C Phi so that rook is completely
trapped and in fact black position is
completely crumbling
my opponent continued here with the MOOC
win capture c7 but after pawn captures
Queen captures and the move Bishop to c3
in just 18 moves White has an exchange
and a two-point advantage with a winning
position okay let's consider the second
reply by the black that is look to a
file well against this I'm recommending
that you should certainly continue with
the moon night jack and after the moon
King to b7 so this line has a great
merit that black has a misplaced king
and white has ample opportunity to
attack black King here Y should continue
with a very tricky move Queen to f3 so
in some lines I can take that rook and
then give the cheque which regained the
piece here there are two replies has
been try and the first game my opponent
continued here with the rook to e4 so
getting out of the attack I continue
with the obvious move Bishop to b5
hitting the rook
one more time and after the move rook to
d4 Queen 283 and d6
I just protect my efore pawn with the
move f3 my opponent continued here with
the move Knight to f6
but Ezreal which happens in this line
that rook is nearly trapped and here
that happens one more time with the mu C
3 so now black has nothing better than
Knight to d7 counter attacking the
bishop but after night to e8 not only
protecting that bishop but definitely
asking a question what you going to do
next after a long thought my opponent
continued with the move Knight captures
b6 I recapture with the night and after
Queen to c7 Knight captures see a Czech
Queen captures and pawn captures rook
after the whole sequence not only white
emerged with an extra pawn and exchange
but blacking is clearly misplace
in the second game where my opponent was
a national master he continued with the
move Knight to f6 here I Castle on the
Queen side my opponent captured a to
pawn
I played King to be one and now he
dropped back the rook today Foursquare
now as usual we are going to attack that
rope with the move Bishop to b5 and as
usual this rook will not find a safe
haven kindly note if rook to before then
Queen to e3 is a very strong reply so in
the game my opponent continued with the
move Knight to d4 attacking to sports I
played Queen to d3 and after Knight
captures and Queen captures black has a
completely lost position rook cannot
capture the e4 pawn as the Queen sefa
check is a very deadly reply also the
move d6 is not good as well the simple
reason is after the move e5 white
obtained of any position so for example
a simple line can run like this Bishop
to d7 pawn check King to d8 Queen to C
Phi push up to c6 and after the move
Knight to a6 black is completely busted
so obviously considering all this at the
end my opponent played the move Knight
to e 8 which is in fact the best move in
this position but nevertheless white
obtained a winning advantage after
Knight to defy check pawn captures and
now simply Queen captures rook with a
huge advantage so let me show you rest
of the moose which will give you a very
good idea how good this position is for
the white my opponent here continue with
the move AB 6 so giving this King some
space I continue here with the move rook
h2 even and after the move King to f 7 I
simply grab the d5 pawn with the rogue
and you can see the pathetic position of
the black pieces they are very much
cramp and white pieces are so much
aggressively place
my opponent here continued with the move
Knight to c7 attacking the rook but
forgetting that White has this dazzling
reply rook captures d7 boom
well black doesn't have any good choice
after Bishop captures and Queen captures
not only white is a clearly to point up
in this position but black has a very
shaky King the game continued here with
the move Bishop captures c7 Queen to see
it trying to exchange the Queen but I
simply keep my attack with the move
Queen to defy check King to a fade and
now Bishop to g3 gives white a
tremendous entertaining and fun to play
position after few moves white managed
to win this game very easily so with
this we come to the final critical
Mumbai the plaque that is Bishop to b4
check and after the obvious moves c3
Black's idea is to play Bishop to e5
we're here why it has nothing better
than giving this check and black reveal
his trump card after queen capture c7
the forcing sequence continued here with
the move Bishop captures and after
Bishop captures black can argue that he
has a three piece for a queen and a pawn
which generally a good trade but not in
this case the simple reason is first of
all white has this move Queen to G for
attacking g7 if King to f8 then I have
included a game in the PGN where black
position is very cramped and later on he
has to play g6 and King to g7 which is a
waste of some moves so instead of that
best move here for the black is to play
g6 and now I'm going to show you a model
game which will highlight how why should
continue in this situation this is a
game from the Russian championship where
the white player is rated to 5 for 2 GM
Varro Bo and he is playing the black
player básico was rated is to 475
here why continue with the move Bishop
to d3 idea is to castle as quickly as
possible
black continued here with the move
Knight G to e7 and White Castle on the
Kings side black does the same and now
the important concept which can be
highlighted in this game that is a for
what white needs to do in such a
scenario is cram this minor pieces and
then slowly building up the attack and
this is exactly we are going to see in
this game black continue here with the
move d6 probably threatening ePHI so
white continue here with the move Queen
to e2 and now black try to unravel his
species with the move Bishop to d7 no
matter
here comes our expansion on the Queen
side with the move before so now white
is all set to cramp black on the Queen
side black continued here with the move
rook F to see aide but after the move fi
it is tremendous that even though black
has few pieces for the Queen those
species are sitting on a very funny
squares finally black decided to open up
the position with the move d5 and white
ignore it and continue his assault on
the Queen side with the move asics
black block thing with the move b6 but
later on it turns out that this is a big
mistake
now white who has space on the Queen
side decided to switch his attention on
the Kings side and he played the best
move the situation that is fo black
continued here with the move rook to e8
and white block on the Kings side with
the move ePHI black tries to unravel his
pieces with the move Knight to e7
but again white put a stamp on the
coincide with the move
b5 still not giving any access to these
minor pieces black plays Bishop to d8
and now slowly white wants to open up
the position with the move c4 so he
first prepare it with the move rook to
see one black continue here with the
move to c8 and after c4 pawn captures
and rook captures White has set up a
very important tactic and in fact black
straight away fall into it at first
sight it looks like Bishop captures
beefer is a great reply but I wonder if
you can spot White's amazing idea kindly
pause the video and find out a sequence
where white obtained a decisive
advantage okay I hope you find this
wonderful sequence that is rook captures
Bishop captures Queen captures and after
Knight captures Queen to d7 black has to
fill the rook with the move rook to her
fate and White has successfully keep
blocking minor pieces out of the game
now comes the second important phase of
the game where white start attacking
black on the Kings side with the MU G
for black continue here with the MU B
Phi so he desperately want to get his
piece to be activated but I think it's
too little too late
white attack crashing through on the
Kings side with the mu F fire black give
this check white plate King to h1 and
now he decided to capture one pawn that
is he kept his F Phi and after G
captures FI he tried to block the things
with the mu G Phi which in fact doesn't
turns out very well because after the
move Epps's white obtained of winning H
black plays rook to d8 white continue
with the move Queen to a5 attacking the
G Phi and after the obvious move at six
White has this little new a6 which is I
think of winning stamp black plate one
more move rook to a fade but after the
movie seven he simply resigned the
simple reason is let's say after rook to
e8 White has this wonderful move Queen
to g6 and after pawn captures and f7 not
only it will create a queen but black
king will be checkmated in few more
so a model demonstration of how to play
with a queen and a pawn against two
minor pieces that's all guys
I hope with this brief analysis you have
now new shocking weapon against Sicilian
tamaño in your armory well thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
this game is the most effective thank
you well here white has this amazing
trick starting with the move Knight to
e4